it's all coming in i think the people
understand it i think that
in many ways we're stronger now than
ever before they understand the
deception
and the the horror that these people put
this country through it's really very
sad actually
let me go into this double standard
issue that i've been discussing here
and and that is you we went through
three years as a country
and i covered it almost every night
every major newspaper
two cable networks that are nothing but
democratic propaganda
abc nbc cbs they all got it wrong about
trump russia collusion
but now we know the truth we know that
hillary clinton paid for the dirty
russian misinformation dossier
that even christopher steele doesn't
stand by and
the sub source doesn't stand by that
dossier she paid for
was then used to spy on you as a
candidate and
a fisa court was lied to and then it was
used again to spy on you as
in your transition phase and then as a
president and we also know that money
from russia made it to a prominent
political family in america
that would be hunter biden's family that
would be joe's
son now again i
ask you that that wasn't the coverage
for three years while you were in office
actually four if you want to include
ukraine um what do you make of the
double standard
some people even get pulitzers over such
phony coverage
well they did get pulitzers and it
turned out to be they got pulitzers for
absolutely incorrect and opposite
reporting it was
horrible reporting and uh there are many
people that should have gotten pulitzers
where they had it right but they were
not considered and it's a disgrace
i think pulitzer is another one that's
been disgraced by this whole last
four and a half year period five year
period but literally from the day
of that wonderful ride down the
escalator from that moment on
uh investigation after investigation
and the people that were guilty uh they
they just float right through how it
wasn't done
doj didn't do anything about it i guess
they felt
they want to be soft this group doesn't
feel that way but
you know what i left that up to doj i
left that up to
the people running doj and i wasn't
involved i
would say that probably maybe less
involved than i should have been maybe i
should have been forcing it
but a lot of very guilty people were
uh not in any way prosecuted
and i'm talking about very very serious
things if you look at comey and mccabe
and the two lovers and all of the things
that went on and they weren't prosecuted
if you read
the horowitz report and of course
everyone's still waiting for durham what
happened to durham
how is that allowed to go into another
administration by the way is he in the
witness protection program
i'd like to know where he is too is he
in the witness protection program
he disappeared and there was so
but you didn't even have to go into
durham you could have just taken the
horowitz report and i have a lot of
respect for
mr horowitz the ig and he wrote a report
that was devastating to comey and
devastating to mccabe and
they didn't do anything with it it's
incredible actually incredible very sad
they're very sad for the country but you
know i guess they felt they shouldn't
and yet this
administration feels the exact opposite
if people don't do anything wrong they
want to go after them
big difference and it's uh you know it's
a
it's a tough standard but hopefully you
have an attorney general now that will
be uh
it will be fair but i will say that the
people running uh the justice but and
the people in it don't forget
you have tens of thousands of people and
they were put there by
uh by obama they were put there by
everybody they were put there by a lot
of people that came including clinton
but they were also put there by bush and
uh
you know you see what goes on with that
whole
group so you have a lot of people put in
there by bush and clinton
you put there by obama and uh then you
put some in yourself and you can't do
anything about it i guess i don't know
but i think that they were very very
soft and maybe rightfully so but they
were very very soft and
uh probably they wanted to be very fair
but a lot of people don't look at it
that way it's it's a shame there was
such guilt and such a horrible thing
happened they were spying on my campaign
you know if you think about it all the
way back almost at the beginning when i
when i made a statement that my campaign
was spied
on it was one of the biggest moments it
was
nobody could believe it then it turned
out that i wish it was more than spied
on much worse than being spied on
but they didn't do anything about it and
uh to me that's a
terrible thing for our country i don't
see that biden got anything from putin
and i can't believe that american energy
workers
were were with a stroke of a pen
lost their high paying career jobs for
the same exact thing
the waiver that that that biden gave on
nordstrom i can't believe it
let me ask you this if you were still
president
would you have given that waiver and
secondly what would you be doing about
the cyber
attacks that are ongoing colonial
pipeline the attacks on our meat
industry
how would you be handling that with
putin
well in the waiver nobody really
understands that i was the one that
stopped it i stopped it from being built
and i went to germany and i said listen
we
protect you with nato at a very low cost
and they're very delinquent
you know they're only paying half of
what they're supposed to be paying and
what they're supposed to be paying is
very low two percent
and they're paying half and so we
protect you we have 52
000 soldiers over there which is like a
major major
city frankly they make a fortune with us
and then they go and they pay russia
billions and billions of dollars for
energy so i said so let's get this
straight to angela
i said we protect you and the people
that we protect you from the country
you're paying billions of dollars how
does that work
and there are others so i got nato to
pay
430 billion dollars more than they were
paying because the united states was
paying for almost all of it
i mean think of it we pay for their
protection
and they excuse the word they screw us
on trade that's the only word that's
really descriptive enough
because they are in many ways worse than
china or as bad
as china on trade how many chevrolets
are being sold in berlin
not too many how many chevrolets are
being sold in paris
not too many maybe none and yet
we sell their products their wines and
their cars and their mercedes and their
bmws and everything else we sell it all
over our country and all of that was
stopping we were
ready to go and then we got hit by the
pandemic and nobody did as good a job
with the pandemic as we did and that's
why we're leading the world in terms of
coming back and that was all set long
before biden came in
including the fact that we came up with
vaccines in less than nine months when
a lot of people everybody said it was
going to take three to five years and
you probably wouldn't be successful
and if we weren't successful sean i'll
tell you this you would have another
1917
tragedy where almost 100 million people
died
but we were successful so it was a great
thing let me ask you
in your summits and in your
conversations with putin while president
um what did you learn about him have you
spoken to him since you left office
and was it a mistake for biden not to
hold that joint press conference with
putin
i got along really well with him nobody
was tougher in russia he would say that
but nobody would was tougher in russia
you never heard of
nordstrom you never heard of all of the
things that we did with in terms of
sanctions so many sanctions
and i would i was loving the idea of
taking them off i would have loved to
have taken them off as soon as they
got their act together i think we had
you know a great
shot at having an unbelievable
relationship with
russia it could have been fantastic it
could have been
really beneficial to both countries you
know they need economics and
we need things that they have where they
have very valuable land in terms of
mineral rights and
many other things and a lot of good
things could have happened i had a very
good relationship with putin but nobody
treated him tougher he understands
nobody ever heard of the pipeline until
i got involved and i said wait a minute
the pipeline's going to germany and all
over europe what's going on
why are we protecting you people you
know again and i
just it was just unbelievable i got
so much for that and to give up the
stoppage i mean we i stopped it
and to give it up and then if you you
see what they did
and the number is really forty eight 000
not 8 000.
but you see what they did with the
keystone xl pipeline
where they stopped it almost on the
first day and that was never mentioned
during the debate i kept saying you know
you're not going to be energy
independent you're not going to do
for pennsylvania for texas for all of
these places
where we're doing so well with energy
we're not going to be energy independent
in two months from now
they're making windmills all over the
place to ruin our land and kill our
birds
to kill everything we're not going to be
and they're very intermittent as you
learn from
watching over the last four months it's
intermittent energy
it's not good it's not going to power
our great factories
and it's the real what did you make yeah
there was a question of what there was a
question of whether ukraine would join
nato and biden's answer is they have to
clean up
corruption and okay so they can't
join nato because they got to clean up
corruption
but his son made a fortune and he
leveraged a billion dollars and bragged
about it
of u.s tax dollars and this is a big
issue to you because you went over an
impeachment over this
leveraged a billion dollars to get a
prosecutor in ukraine fired
he's got six hours to do it and son of a
b they did it
now i'm just imagining if they're too
corrupt to join nato
how come it's okay then for hunter to
make all that money when he admitted on
good morning america he had no
experience in energy gas
uh ukraine and got millions of dollars
what if your sons got millions of
dollars for that with no experience
well when he said that i was very
surprised that he said it because he
said basically ukraine is corrupt
and that was the whole purpose of what
was going on and frankly we had an
obligation
even a legal obligation and we have an
agreement signed with ukraine
and that agreement says you got to be
honest you got to run a straight
country and they don't do that and when
i saw that
slap and i was surprised because i guess
you hear different numbers but it's
183 000 a month for his son
to consult on energy from an energy
company in ukraine
to consult on energy but he admits that
he knows nothing about energy the whole
thing is
just terrible the money from russia
three and a half million dollars from
the
wife of the mayor of moscow the former
mayor of moscow
we no longer have a fair and free press
whether you like it or not
and i hate to say it to you because
you're a big believer in the press
despite what you go through but we no
longer have
a free and fair press i i said in 2007
sir i didn't i wish i came up with fake
news but i did say journalism in america
is dead and i don't think i was wrong i
think i probably understated it
let me ask this um because
two weeks last week joe biden said to
our military
that global warming was the biggest
threat they faced the week before he had
said white supremacy is the biggest
threat to america
um i don't know i think china russia
north korea the iranian muellers might
be bigger threats radical islamic
terrorism
what's your reaction to that answer
well he said that the military told him
and the generals that
which was i can't believe that but uh
maybe but they shouldn't be working as
generals any longer that
uh global warming is the our biggest
threat now when you look at china and
you look at the military apparatus which
i was really
doing a big job on i have a very good
relationship there too it was a
fantastic relationship
until kovit where the china virus came
in and after that
you know we made a great trade deal
where the farmers of this country and
the manufacturers are doing
fantastically because of
that trade your farmers are doing better
than they've ever done now and that's
because of what i did not because of
what these guys did
and we did a fantastic thing
but when you look at it and when you
look at what happened sean and
you you see that horrible that horrible
thing
that came at us from china and came at
us
from the wuhan the wuhan lab
it changed my whole line of thinking and
and you just
i i really hope and i believe it was an
accident it was incompetence i guess
some people don't necessarily agree with
that they think maybe there was purpose
to it
which would be uh absolutely terrible
but we have to find out more about it
why did it happen how did it happen how
could anybody be so incompetent
and that is not a group of incompetent
people
so president can i add one thing here i
believe it i believe it was a terrible
accident but i believe it came from the
lab
and why would you think it's an accident
we all we
we knew there was actually video out now
of bats
in the wuhan virology lab
we knew that they studied coronaviruses
and we now know from the emails from the
great dr fauci flip-flopper that
that gain of function research was being
done there so it seems like the most
logical conclusion the only question is
is there a possibility that u.s tax
dollars help pay for the
gain of function leading to covert 19.
well we ended that john and when we
heard about it i ended that
but that started in 2014 under obama
and when i heard about it we ended it
very rapidly
i said can you imagine and it wasn't
even wuhan it was just that we were
paying china on top of everything else
we're now paying for
their research and other things
ridiculous so we ended that
as soon as we heard about it and we did
a lot of things against
china not that i want to be against
china because i had a great relationship
with president xi a lot of respect for
him
but uh i banned china from coming into
the country
very early before anybody fauci nancy
pelosi was dancing in the streets of
china francisco and they were all
saying what i did was xenophobic and
horrible and racist
and then they said four months later i
saved thousands and thousands of lives
but i banned china from coming in and
it's lucky i did and then i banned
europe from coming in because you saw
what was happening
especially in certain countries in
europe and i banned europe from coming
in
and everybody said that was terrible but
we saved tens of thousands of lives and
now we have to get back and the schools
have to get open and frankly uh
we're lucky we have the vaccine but the
vaccine on very young people is
something that you gotta really stop you
have to get
back to running your country i mean i
don't
see reasons and i am a big believer in
what we did with the vex it's incredible
what we did
you see the results but to have every
school child
where it's 99.99
they just don't you know they're just
not affected or affected badly
having to receive a vaccine i think is
something that you should start thinking
about because i think it's unnecessary
you want china to pay 10 trillion
dollars don't you
well the number is much higher than that
but there's only so much they can pay
and that's to us and the world is the
number is bigger throughout the world
look countries have been destroyed
over what they did and whether by
accident or not and i would hope that it
was accident i hope
that it was through incompetence or an
accident
but when you look whether it was by an
accident
whether it was whatever it is
this you look at these countries they'll
never ever be the same
our country was hit so hard but other
countries were hit much harder
look at what's going on in india now you
know they used to say oh look how well
india is doing because they're always
looking for an excuse look how well
india's doing
the fact is that india has just been
devastated now
and virtually every country has been
devastated
no i think i think that's one of the
reasons that i feel it's very important
to find out where it came from how it
came
i think i know i mean i feel certain
about it
but certainly china should help
right now their economy and our economy
are the two economies that come
that are coming back the fastest i mean
if you think about it
uh in certain ways maybe they were they
benefited very greatly
i mean very very greatly and i can tell
you they benefited with the us
because we were in a process of doing
things where we caught up to china at a
level that nobody thought was possible
and once the china virus came in we had
to take a very different look you know
the world changed the whole world
changed you didn't think about
the economics you think you thought
about saving people and saving lives so
the world changed it was a different
whole different ballgame we did we did
the great trade deal
a big piece of it but we did the great
trade deal and it helped a lot of people
manufacturers and farmers in particular
but but
you know after after that horrible
disease floated in from china
however it came in and it came in
through numerous ways
once that disease came in from china i
had a whole different attitude
it was a terrible thing let me ask you
about let me go back to the campaign and
i'm going to play a tape for you here
um i've compared joe biden i've shown
video of him from 2012
2016. he i called you know he lived in
his basement bunker throughout most of
the campaign in 2020
i i used to argue he was in the big tech
media mob protection program and they
let him hide and get away without
answering many questions
did the bare minimum of anybody
campaigning
and i have a highlight reel that i put
together
but i'm i'm saving that for another day
but this happened at the g7
joe's had a lot of these um cognitive
misfires let's call it that
and this is the one that he had because
he had called putin a killer then he was
asked about it
he didn't want to give that answer
because he's about to meet with putin
and your reaction to joe and
and do you think he's up to the job
physically mentally
let me play this vladimir putin
laughed at the suggestion that you had
called him a killer
is that still your belief sir that he is
a killer
[Laughter]
answer the first question i'm laughing
too
they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was
uh there are certain things that he
would do or
did do you know i do make fun of it
but in all seriousness mr president that
scares the hell out of me
have you noticed the same well maybe the
only time i've ever
disagreed with you is about the age
because i guess joe is going
on to be 79 fairly soon
and that's not old relatively speaking i
know
bernie marcus a great gentleman founder
of home depot oh
bernie sanders 100 i spoke to him he's a
hundred percent and other people are in
their 90s and 80s and they're doing
great
so you know his age is not the problem
and look i hope he has no problems i
want him to do well
i want him to go out and do well i think
the election was
unbelievably unfair but i want this guy
to go out and do well for our country i
don't want to see a scene like that i
watched that yesterday i thought it was
terrible it was terrible nobody knew
what was happening
let me move on to the economy we now
have
inflation we now have jobs that people
aren't taking
and businesses now are are turning down
the federal government's extended
unemployment uh benefits
uh the price of lumber through the roof
the price of gasoline up an
average a dollar ten per gallon the
price to heat and cool your home is up
the price of meat is skyrocketing lumber
skyrocketing
every item that you buy in any store
that is
delivered by a truck you are paying a
lot more for
and i'm looking at it and and we're
getting rid of energy independence which
you gave us as president for the first
time in 75 years
what is your take on the state of the
economy and the impact
the current border crisis has on it and
i want i'll do a follow-up on that
so the lumber is really a function of
supply and demand we have so much but
they're putting environmental
restrictions on trees now that are so
bad and we're
trying to make deals with canada i can
tell you from personal experience canada
is very very tough
canada is uh as tough as anybody they
they it's very unfair the way canada
treats us and
i had it down to a science it was so
good it was so
we were doing so well everything was
coming down
we signed the usmca mexico canada
but we were not being taken advantage of
anymore and i was going to tariff the
hell out of their cars coming into the
united states if they did and they knew
it
and as soon as i left they started
playing games and now you look at lumber
prices because we get a lot from canada
and you look at what's going on with
milk and the fact that they don't take
us but we take them so many things they
did the farmer that i straightened out
and now
it's going back to worse than it was
because there's nobody there
complaining about it you know canada
treats this country very very badly
so does europe by the way and china you
know about but as i say in many ways
europe treats us just as badly as china
let me let me ask this question and i
want to ask it
and i'll ask you about 2022 and 2024 in
a minute it seems to me that
conservatism and i remember i know maybe
you do
or you don't when you were thinking
about running for president times that
i'd interview you and private
conversations we'd have at the time
i explained what i believed in i really
haven't changed much i believe in
liberty freedom
capitalism our constitution low taxes
less government interference bureaucracy
a constitutionalist on the bench school
choice
law and order safety and security so
people can pursue happiness
free market solutions for health care
including protecting pre-existing
conditions
i want secure borders uh i absolutely
positively want energy independence for
a lot of reasons
and free and fair trade and peace
through strength
that pretty much sums up sean hannity's
philosophy
it was talk that you are considering
maybe
laying out the trump america first
make america great again agenda how
close
is my lifelong hell beliefs
to what you would put on paper if you
ever considered it and are you
considering it
well i am and frankly if you think of it
that's what i've been doing and talking
about for
a long time hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else